Darhk,s in the wind the longer he is there the harder he is gonna be to catch
you should know that whatever your play is I got your back
Where's Darhk?
and you are beginning
and you will have it once we brouht this world to its end
felicity is out of surgery. He didn't say what's wrong
I'm gonna kill him
Hey youtubers this is charlie. This is gonna be my Arrow video. We are just breaking down the latest trailer. Just confirming a couple of things that we already knew
Ok the biggest thing about this trailer is that they say that Felicity is coming out of surgery they just kinda confirm that she is not gonna died
I know a lot of you asking me Is she turning into Oracle character
When they actually made the Felicity episode last year, what they did was that the first title they used was oracle
But Warner bros. was like that you can't use that. but we are using Barbara Gordon  oracle character in some thing else. I think its gonna for the teen titans show.
So they changed the name of Felicity episode to the  Secret origin of felicity smoak. That was Dark Felicity if guys don't remember.
I expecting a version of Oliver last season where he is kind of out of commission for a couple of episodes but not dead definitely not dead
the other part of the trailer is that this attack catalyzing team arrow coming together Diggle is no more Diggle against Oliver. He is like what ever you gonna do man whomever spine you gonna break I am  totally behind you.
So the other big thing is that we see the Anarchy symbol again
I think this person here is the evolution of Anarchy character that ran away. In the comics he wears a version of mask like this.this is  just like truer to life. His face is completely messed up remember.
This other woman is the person that we saw with Damien Darhk in the mid season finale along with that child. So its either his wife or some sort of partner.
Well he talks about fulfilling a promise. I am wondering he is bringing back someone from  the dead raising crazy magic what ever the pact he's made
He does seems a family man very evil family man and they did say that one of the big themes of Arrow season 4 is what would you do for your family .
I am guessing that this the Damien Darhk side of the equation. but usually they are talking about arrow characters.like Oliver's family is team arrow what would he do for them crazy stuff
Damien Darhk's side of the story is gonna be told in the second half of the season.
The biggest thing that's coming on the show is that Felicity's father is coming to the show and its gonna be the Roy episode. I think I already talked about it in some of my previous arrow videos
He is the calculator and he is going to be blackmailing Roy into committing crimes for him.
So what might end up happening is felicity might be out of commission  and it just like Oliver came charging in
in this big zip chord felicity might end up getting a version of that which she needs to take her father down talk about daddy issues.